I read it read a very interesting book a
while back called the wealth and poverty
of Nations that was written by a Harvard
emeritus professor of history and one of
the things that he claimed I liked it I
thought it was very smart was that the
only true natural resource is
interpersonal trust if you can set up a
society where people trust each other
then it will instantly become rich and
he used the example of Japan which is a
very conscientious society and very rich
Society but the Japanese have no natural
resources right none to speak of and yet
they're rich and then you have countries
like the Soviet Russia and and much of
South America where there's just natural
resources but you know they're just like
Venezuela just more natural resources
than you know what to do with and the
places are absolute catastrophes
absolute catastrophe of cynicism and
corruption and so he attempted to
document the relationship between
default interpersonal trust among
citizens within countries and their
their productivity in their GDP and
their standard of living and found a
very very tight relationship and and I
like that a lot and I've got a story
about that quickly that I think is very
interesting I'll tell you two stories
one sort of generic well I'll tell you
one personal first so one day I lent my
car to one of my graduate students and
he took it to Montreal this old Cadillac
and mmm he got it was a really bad
rainstorm in Montreal and he was in one
of the highways that are like set into
the ground and there was like six inches
of water and he was turning a corner hit
the brakes and skidded on the water and
smacked it into the wall and on the
corner of the of the bumper you know and
so then he brought it back and he was
very apologetic about it and and his
name was Matt Shane tell you that
because Matt might hear this and I could
shame him a bit for doing this 20 years
ago you know and he's a professor at the
Ontario Institute of Technology I think
now I'm quite a successful one but
anyways he brought the car back and I
went and got it evaluated for damages it
was like seventeen hundred dollars or
something to repair it and or maybe more
but it was almost as much as the car was
worth I thought well I'm not gonna do
that so I went online and I typed in the
part
and if you do that you can get people to
bid on sending you a used part from all
over North America so that's kind of
cool so there's all these junk dealers
have got together and they have this you
know network of communication so you put
in the car part and then they send you a
bid and so this guy said well I'll send
you the bumper assembly which is the
whole bumper and the lights for like 250
bucks and I thought yeah okay you could
do that that'd be good so then I said
yes and then he called me up about half
an hour later this guy from way down
south he had a really deep sort of
Mississippi accent he said wait a sec
was that for the bumper or the bumper
assembly and I said what was for the
bumper assembly he said oh I thought it
was for the bumper and then he said but
that's ok I'll send it to you anyways I
thought well that's pretty good so I
said well thank you and then I hung up
and then half an hour later he called me
up again and he said look I just went
out and looked at that bumper assembly
and there's a plastic trim piece on the
side and it has a scratch in it and I
thought I'd better tell you that just in
case you didn't want it I thought wow
that's so amazing it's like there's a
miracle man it's like this guy he's
somewhere in Mississippi I'm never gonna
see him again ever I'm never gonna have
any contact with him like he made a bad
deal right because the part was worth
more than he decided to sell it to me
forever but he stuck with his deal and
then he went over and above the call of
duty he said well this part that I'm
selling you to you for way less than
it's worth is damaged so I thought I'd
better tell you it's like man you got to
recognize a miracle when you see one
that was a miracle so I said hey look
it's thanks for calling man it's okay I
can handle the scratch said the part
needed and and I got the car fixed and
forgave Matt and you know it had a happy
ending so so that's trust
right because I didn't know him from
Adam and he's a primate full of snakes
just like the rest of us and yet he was
willing to simplify himself to the point
where I could just take him absolutely
at his word and that meant we could
trade even though we were strangers it's
like man do not underestimate the
utility of that and then there's eBay so
when he Bay first started you know the
idea was it's not gonna work because
you'll send me junk and I'll send you a
check that bounces and that'll be the
end of eBay right and so these escrow
agents popped up so you could insure
your train
action with the moves for like 10% of
the transaction they would get the check
and the goods and make sure that they
were okay and then send them on or
ensure the transaction but what happened
was the escrow agents didn't make any
money and the reason for that was no one
cheated now you think about how amazing
that is right you bring these people
together across a whole continent
they've never seen each other before
they're never going to interact with
each other again and this was before
there were any reputation ratings on
eBay and yet the default transaction was
you describe your goods
honestly including their flaws you set a
reasonable price I decide to pay you
ship the goods and I pay you and it
works and what happened was that eBay
produced it produced a tremendous amount
of capital that was previously frozen so
frozen capitalists when you have
invested money in something but the
thing is no longer useful to you so the
money is just sitting there frozen right
so to speak and you can't get it loose
because well you've got attic full of
junk how are you gonna get rid of that
oh we may and so all of a sudden all
these things that were just junked
became valuable and everybody got richer
and none of that wouldn't it would have
happened without the Covenant that we
established between each other that's
predicated on trust and so you might say
that Trust is the currency and currency
is trust because it's a promissory note
right and if people lie then the
currency gets to based very very rapidly
and so the economy runs on trust